Resorts World opened back in June of
2021 now the 4.3 billion dollar Resort
hard to miss with its 100
000 square foot LED screen right on the
side of the building but
head north into the strip Good Day Las
Vegas anchor Heather Mills stopped by to
find out what's on tap and what's coming
down the pipeline
two years ago these doors opened with
ambition to excitement and expectation
to transform the North End of the strip
one the first ground up property built
on the strip in more than a decade
Stakes were high now when you look at
what we've been able to accomplish in
such a short period of time you know
when we open this property the initial
concept was we were going to lean into
entertainment and it's paid off Carrie
Underwood Luke Bryan Katy Perry and that
doesn't even include the nightclub which
hosts other famous entertainers like
Travis Scott Tiesto and Jack Harlow just
to name a few
entertainment has been a huge part Chief
marketing officer Ron Nicoli says the
process has been an evolution we
continue to refine and adapt right and
again I think that all comes with kind
of going through that first two years of
operation including some dining changes
it really is a a food Journey but we
have adapted it and put some more
Western options in there Nicoli says
they've captured the convention crowd as
anticipated as Tesla's zip underneath
Resorts World to and from the convention
center with heavy frequency but he
admits there's still work to do to
capture the local audience not even just
that that call that Monday through
Thursday type of traffic to the property
we want this to be a place where they
want to come as for the future I love
the fact that Fountain Blue is opening
because it further strengthens this
North position nikoli says Resort world
will rule the world
saying they're leaning into what's
becoming a Melting Pot of personalities
appetites and culture Heather Mills 8
News Now
as for what's next in the entertainment
lineup Resorts World is staying
tight-lipped but promises some big names
and some big shows in the coming year